[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to Harry
Potter Theory today we'll be discussing
Ron Weasley and all of the problems
associated with his wand A Wizard's wand
is his most important tool it's the
conduit of his power and for most the
only way they'll ever be able to conjure
spells so if once were so important why
did the Weasley family decide to give
Ron a hand me down wand that never
really served him well in fact Ron's
earliest wand was so bad that many of
his instructors at Hogwarts could never
shake their first impression of the boy
that he was a subpar wizard so why
didn't Ron have his own wand why was he
given Charlie and why did it take him so
long to get a new one we'll answer these
questions and More in today's video
Ron's first wand when we go back to Ron
Weasley's very first year we'll find him
in an awkward situation unlike Harry
Potter herione and most other children
on the Hogwarts Express Ron wasn't
adorned in a lot of new clothes and he
didn't possess many new items and when
the food trolley aboard the train rolled
by known then as the honeydukes express
Ron wasn't able to buy very much in the
Weasley household gallions and sickles
weren't easy to come by with one of the
largest families in the pure blood
Community the Weasleys had more than
enough mouths to feed at one point poor
m and Arthur Weasley Ron's parents had
to feed clothe and house seven children
Bill Charlie Percy Fred George Ron and
Jenny keeping up with all of your
children's peers was hard enough when
you had just one but the weasy had seven
they could hardly afford to buy the
greatest owls fanciest robes or most
powerful ones for each one and when it
became Ron's turn to attend Hogwart
School of which craft and Wizardry the
Weasley seemed to finally come up short
instead of visiting visiting olivander's
one shop in Dagon alley they simply
handed Ron one of the ones from his
older brother Charlie with that in his
hand and a trunk full of other
hand-me-downs the Weasley sent the
youngest boy off to school now when we
ask why the Weasley would give Ron
Charlie's old wand I think the answer is
pretty obvious they didn't have enough
money or at least that's what we've been
led to assume but in that very same year
the Weasley made some other odd choices
with their finances the might make you
question their reasoning to congratulate
Ron's older brother Percy for becoming a
prefect Arthur and Molly purchased him
an owl and robes now considering how
much trouble Ron had with magic and how
much this would affect his self-esteem
in the coming years investing so much in
Percy's presence seems a bit misguided
if the Weasley parents had spent more
time thinking about what Ron would need
in order to succeed in his classes then
they would have realized that perhaps
Charlie's old wand wouldn't be good
enough after all Garrick olivander said
it best when he claimed the one chooses
the wizard that much has always been
clear to those of us who have studied
WLW if you are any wizard at all you
will be able to channel your magic
through almost any instrument the best
results however must always come where
there is the strongest Affinity between
Wizard and wand these connections are
complex an initial attraction and then a
mutual quest for experience the ones
learning from The Wizard the wizard from
the wand it seems unlikely that Arthur
and Molly Weasley would have disagreed
with olivander on this point so their
choice to blow their education budget on
Percy's gifts seems all the more strange
in fact this has led many outside
observers to suggest that the Weasley
family wasn't poor because of a lack of
income but simply because they failed to
manage their money properly whatever the
case might have been Ron's first year at
Hogwarts was hardly that of a magical
Prodigy the combination of an fitting
wand combined with the pressure of his
older brother's great successes was all
a bit too much for Ron to handle sure he
provided his courage while helping his
close friend Harry Potter protect the
philosopher stone from Voldemort but Ron
failed to make a positive impression on
his teachers it didn't help that the two
people he sat next to everyday in class
Harry Potter and tomione Granger were
among the most skilled wizards of their
generation either breaking his wand but
Run's time with Charlie's wand would be
short lived on the day Ron was supposed
to arrive for the full semester of his
second year the youngest Weasley boy
broke his wand that was not the worst
thing to happen on the day but it would
have the longest impact on his Year Ron
was far too afraid of his parents to
report his broken one to them so for the
rest of the Year Ron simply suffered
through class with a wand that was
patched up and barely held together
throughout the year whenever Ron would
try to produce spells they would
regularly backfire or Worse cause so
much harm that he was sent to the
healers once is W even hit a professor
squarely on his head but Ron's first
wand was useful for one thing when
Professor gildor Lockhart ripped the
magical device from the children's hands
and tried to use it to cast a memory
charm the want did exactly what it had
done all year backfired instead of
wiping Ron's mind and those of his
friends it scrambled Professor lockards
leaving him incapacitated for the rest
of his life you w
but that runin with Professor lockart
was about as bad as things would get for
Ron at least when it came to his ones
before the start of Ron's thirdd year at
Hogwarts his parents bought him a brand
new one from olivander's shop and his
ability to cast spells and perform magic
dramatically improved that year although
he was still a bit behind his friends
Harry and Hermione Ron was nothing like
he was during his second year with his
new wand Ron's confidence also grew and
he found himself a bit less burdened by
the legacy of his older brothers
confident and with a new wand in his
grasp Ron went on to become quite a
competent student and as Voldemort
shadow Rose and his Gathering Army of
death heaters struck out against Harry
Potter's allies Ron proved just how
capable he and his new wand were Ron
grew to be such a skilled spellcaster
that he even disarmed Bellatrix the
strange and he didn't even use his wand
to do it he had disarmed Peter betru
shortly earlier and used that former
Marauders wand to get the jump on
Bellatrix which was no small feat she
was considered by many to be Voldemort's
most powerful follower after all she
managed to kill Sirus Black and was more
than lethal with her own wand conclusion
when we look back at Ron's first wand it
is oddly enough still a mystery as to
why his parents Arthur and Molly decided
to give it to him again as we've said
the obvious reason would be the
Weasley's unfortunate lack of finances
but that first wand certainly put Ron on
an uphill path without a properly suited
W from olivanders he'd never quite
achieve the same finesse with his spells
that his peers would and that would only
compound his already substantial
self-esteem issues the Weasley parents
must have been oblivious to just how
much harm they were doing to Ron when
they gave him Charlie's wand but if they
had to do it all over again hopefully
they would have decided to forgo Percy's
gifts and would have fought Ron the
perfect one for his first day at
Hogwarts and that's it for this video I
hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
Ron's first wand and the effects it had
on his magical abilities during his
first few years at Hogwarts what do you
think do you think Ron's self-esteem and
by extension his spellcasting abilities
were deeply affected by his secondhand
wand do you think the Weasley parents
made a poor choice when they decided to
give Ron his Elder Brothers wand I can't
help but wonder if Ron could have
surprised us in his first two years and
learned to love the classes at Hogwarts
maybe he would have taken after his
older brother Percy and discovered his
knack for magic or Ron would have simply
felt a bit more confident and wouldn't
have been so bothered when Draco and his
goons teased him in the corridors
between classes that alone would have
been worth the price of a new wand from
olivanders until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
live
[Music]